ich hatte darüber nachgedacht zu machen
für dieses video
aber dann ist mir eingefallen dass ich
eigentlich immer wie eine kartoffel
aussehen wenn die schäden gehen mit den
gemütlichsten löchrigste pulli überhaupt
mit knödel haaren und einer unglaublich
dreckigen hose
deswegen bekommt ihr heute lieber die
authentische garten experience das passt
ja auch ganz gut zu unserem heutigen
thema denn heute werden wir über
kartoffeln sprechen
genauer gesagt über die winter pflanzung
oder die herbst pflanzen von kartoffeln
also lasst uns gleich loslegen und
schnappt euch eure kartoffeln und
probiert das auch mal zu hause aus es
ist so kalt draußen und marie geht raus
und pflanzt ihre kartoffeln noch vor dem
winter warum das denn so aber so hat ist
das gar nicht ich habe nämlich ganz viel
über eine alte irische technik gelesen
und das möchte ich dieses jahr unbedingt
ausprobieren und das möchte ich euch
auch nicht vorenthalten so dass ihr das
auch in ihrem garten ausprobieren kann
könnt ich immer in die kamera alles denn
dann spreche ich wörter anders aus als
sonst ihr könnt die sache nach dem
garten ausprobieren und zwar ist die
idee eigentlich ganz simpel wer schon
mal kartoffeln angebaut hat der kennt
das wahrscheinlich dass wenn man welche
bei der ernte übersieht die im nächsten
jahr einfach wieder weiter wachsen als
ob es nie ein winter gegeben hätte und
dann überall im garten wieder die
kartoffeln aufklappen und das kann man
sich auch zunutze machen und die
kartoffeln im beet überwintern so dass
man nächstes jahr früher ernten kann
in irland ist das so entstanden dass die
leute versucht haben frühkartoffeln im
boden einzulagern
weil wenn man früh kartoffelsorten
erhalten möchte da hat man es oft ein
bisschen schwer weil die ja schon früh
im jahr geerntet werden und es dann noch
schwieriger ist die über den warmen
sommer und dann bis zur nächsten
pflanzzeit einzulagern so dass sie dann
immer noch schön kein weg sind also so
ist das entstanden dass leute einfach
die frühkartoffeln tief in den boden
eingegraben
um sie zu überwintern und dann sind da
raus kartoffeln gewachsen und die haben
gemerkt war das ist ja total praktisch
weil so können wir noch sie früher im
jahr unsere kartoffeln ernten und ja ich
bin mir ziemlich sicher dass es in sehr
vielen gegenden in deutschland und
österreich und auch in der schweiz
funktioniert also wenn ihr schon mal die
erfahrung gemacht hat dass kartoffeln
bei euch im beet wieder aufgehen die ihr
letztes jahr übersehen habt dann
probiert es auf jeden fall mal aus bei
uns wird es auf jeden fall klappen und
ich bin sehr gespannt wie die erträge
seien wären also werden wir das jetzt
mal ausprobieren
wir verwenden dafür eine frühe
kartoffelsorte oder zumindest keine ganz
späte sorte damit das auch klappt das
man dann früher im jahr ernten kann und
worauf ich auch noch achten würde was
ich jetzt immer wieder gelesen habe auch
in diesem alten büchern war dass man ein
bisschen größere pflanzkartoffeln nehmen
soll als man sonst nimmt ich verwende
zum pflanzen immer die ganz kleinen mini
kartoffeln die man so erntet und
eigentlich kein bock hat die zu stellen
die beheben wir dann einfach auf und
pflanzen die im darauf folgenden jahr
aber ich würde schon darauf achten dass
die mindestens so eine größe haben weil
man die tiefe einpflanzt und dann
brauchen die bisschen mehr power um
diese tiefe erdschicht zu durchdringen
im frühling und dann auch dadurch
wachsen zu können und die kartoffel ist
ja das speicherorgane das heißt da kommt
die erste energie her die die pflanze
hat deswegen würde ich darauf achten er
kartoffeln in seiner größe zu pflanzen
und nicht die ganz ganz ganz klein wenn
du die pflanze dann solltest du die
etwas tiefer pflanzen als sonst so haben
jetzt ungefähr 20 zentimeter tief
eingegraben so dass die im boden noch
ein bisschen besser isoliert sind der
boden schützt die dann ja auch vor zu
starken pfosten und dann habe ich noch
eine mulchschicht draufgepackt die ja
auch nochmal isolierend wirkt um die
bisschen einzuholen aber sonst
funktioniert das eigentlich wie das ganz
normale kartoffelpflanzen im mai oder im
april das man sonst macht und ja ich bin
super gespannt was dabei rauskommt wie
die erträge seien werden es ist ja super
schön wenn man noch früher im jahr
kartoffeln ernten kann ich kann das kaum
abwarten wenn die ersten kartoffeln
schmecken auch so gut oder
und es ist immer so ein fest für uns ich
werde euch natürlich berichten wie es
klappt dann ist es ja eine sache die ich
machen
da ist dass ich den mulch im frühjahr
sagen wir mal im februar bei seite
ziehen werde
vielleicht auch schon im januar weil
sich der boden dann sehr viel besser
erwärmt wenn die sonnenstrahlen direkt
auf den schwarzen dunklen boden fallen
können und nicht von dem wo ich
abgebremst werden dann wachsen die
pflanzen noch viel früher und der boden
erwärmt sich schneller man kann den
früher nutzen also das mache ich
generell in meinem garten immer am
anfang des jahres bis februar ungefähr
entferne ich den kompletten milch so
dass sich der boden schneller aufwärmen
kann weil das ist ein nachteil von mulch
dass er den boden eben gut isoliert aber
eben auch gar nicht wieder wärmer wird
und dann ist es schade wenn der garten
hinterher hängt nur weil man die beete
gemacht hat wenn man hat ja sonst
eigentlich super viele vorteile aber
darauf würde ich immer achten beim
mulchen diese wild aufgehenden
kartoffeln die ernten wir auf jeden fall
immer super gerne und auch früh im jahr
also da machen wir das eigentlich schon
aber eben noch nicht beabsichtigt und ja
ich bin gespannt sein ganzes beete
anzulegen und zu gucken wie das beim
laufen wird also schreibt gerne eure
erfahrungen in die kommentare und auch
wenn ihr noch mehr tipps habt wenn ihr
irgendwelche sorten empfehlungen hp
leckere kartoffeln da freuen sich sicher
auch viele also vor allem die frühen
oder mittelfrühen kartoffelsorten
verwenden und nicht die ganz späten und
schaut mal unten in die kommentare was
die anderen geschrieben haben da sind
sicher ganz viele tolle tipps und ideen
dabei ist es immer so schön dass dafür
ein austausch herrscht und ich freue
mich immer über jeden der ein
kommentator ist es gibt regen sowie
gerade dabei sind ich bin aus der
zukunft also als ich das kartoffel video
gefilmt habe wussten wir noch gar nicht
dass wir so bald ausziehen müssen aber
ja ich bin total überwältigt von ihrem
ganzen von ihrem ganzen feedback auf das
letzte video von ihrem ganzen leben
nachrichten und vor allem von den ganzen
haus angeboten die wir seitdem per e
mail zugeschickt bekommen haben es ist
unglaublich ich hätte nie niemals damit
gerechnet dass sich so viele leute für
uns einsetzen und dass sich da so viele
tolle sachen auftun ich hoffe dass du
mir geschrieben hast dass du es mir nach
sie ist wenn wir erst mal zeit brauchen
das alles zu organisieren also insgesamt
haben uns über 1000 nachrichten erreicht
ich versuche auf jeden fall so vielen
von euch wie möglich zurück zu schreiben
und wenn wenn du uns ein angebot
geschickt hast was wirklich passt also
was ihr dagegen dass wir müssen in der
gegend casting bleiben weil wir hier
arbeiten und bei unser sohn hier zur
schule geht also wir können nicht nach
ungarn ist wahrscheinlich sehr spannend
und cool wäre und auch nicht nach bayern
oder sonst irgendwo hin aber danke danke
danke für eure ganzen lieben wünsche und
die ganzen zuschriften ist es
unglaublich ich weiß gar nicht wie jetzt
anfangen soll das überhaupt erst mal
alles zu ordnen
ich bin komplett von den socken und ich
hoffe dass uns niemand böse ist wenn sie
entweder eine weile brauchen um zurück
zu schreiben oder die vielleicht keine
antwort bekommt weil wir haben gerade so
viel zu tun mit dem umzug und das alles
zu organisieren und es würde
wahrscheinlich wochen dauern
jede einzelne nachricht und jede mail zu
beantworten also hoffentlich seid ihr
uns da nicht böse und dankeschön das ist
unglaublich falls jetzt keine ahnung hat
wovon ich rede
schau mal das video da oben an wir
müssen leider hier ausziehen und ja
danke schön
jetzt gehts weiter mit dem kartoffel
jetzt wenn der winter vor der tür steht
es ist super schön finde ich sich mit
der anbauplanung zu beschäftigen darüber
zu träumen was man nächstes jahr im
garten alles anbauen möchte und wirklich
wilde große träume zu haben und die zu
papier zu bringen dazu gibt es auf jeden
fall auch noch ein paar videos dieses
jahr ansonsten schau dir gerne da
trieben meine playlist zur anbauplanung
an
da habe ich schon letztes jahr ganz
viele videos drüber gemacht und da unten
verlege ich dir noch die playlist zur
selbstversorgung im winter wenn du
wissen willst was jetzt im garten noch
ansteht und was du noch machen kannst um
im winter immer noch aus seinem garten
zu essen
ansonsten sehen wir ins nächsten samstag
wieder biss dann tschüss